this is a [__] crazy story and i'm
gonna drop it on you [__] it's
like the extra added bonus
i walk into the bar one day and then
because at one point i had to go to
school
and after school i had to go help my
mother at the bar load the beer and the
ice and clean the woman's bathroom and
because my mother was buying you had to
stick your hand that little box and
everything my mom didn't [__] around
i had to go down there from three to
like 4 30 and clean the bar
so one day i walk in there
and i see there was like two bookies
leonardo and his brother used to hang at
my mom's bar and there was this guy that
would just dance all day
he would just put on cuban music and get
all [__] up
and dance and throw kicks and my mom
would tell me
sit down you [__] he would still be
dancing
he was like a dancer in cuba and he
couldn't come you know something
happened to me got hit in the head or
something he couldn't stop dancing
he couldn't stop i swear to god he'd go
to the bar have a drink put three
quarters in the jukebox
and he just danced by himself
and he'd shake his shoulders i loved it
i loved it so i walk in one day
and uh you know listen i always seen
cops come into my mother's bar
for their envelope they come in once a
week you know your window gets broken
you got to call the cops we're going to
be here first so we come we come and get
my mother would give like two guys
envelopes like a
a local cop and like a county cop you
know it was well known it's just a price
to do business bro
they come in you give them 200 and they
leave somebody gets shot in your ball
they come in they hide the body they'll
take care of the [__] body
so i come in one day and there's this
and all the patients are sitting at the
barn is this [__] guy with long hair
and another guy and they're yelling at
my mother
and i walk in i'm like what the [__] is
this [__]
and this guy's like my mother's like
what
[__] putta means [__] if you
don't watch sesame street
right so a lot of people don't watch
sesame street the
the count teaches spanish i got to take
the [__] job tonight
so puta means [__] you know i'm saying
that what the [__]
you don't call my mother a putin the guy
was a cop an undercover cop that was
shaking my mom down
so i guess my mom went to give him a
drink and he's like shall just drink up
your [__] ass i want the money you're
making and my mom's like i don't know
what the [__] you talking about guy
you ain't getting no money out of here
you want a little envelope for 100
that's it
he's like i'm your [__] partner all
this [__] in spanish
so that happened i didn't see the guy
for like a month another day i walk in
and this guy's in there yelling again
he's young at the bookies i'm gonna come
in here and bust all these
and they're like [__] you guy you know
we got nothing on us you want to search
us whatever
and he left i don't think about it now
at this time it's like 1975 76 a couple
cuban bars that opened up this is
union city is the second biggest cuban
population in the country they do
embroidery there it's so big for
embroidery
so when the cubans came in 59 they had
billboards in miami that said come to
union city
if you don't want to hang out with this
[__] miami [__] in the heat
so a lot of people went up there my
father was the first councilman up there
the first cuban councilman my real
father so
it's just we had connections in that
town and now one day this cop is
breaking that ball so i go in there one
day
and all these cops and my step bars at
the thing and
all these other cubans were in there
there were bar owners and they're like
what are we gonna do and i'm listening
to this conversation i'm like making a
sandwich but i'm listening to these
[__] saying listen
we're going to do something about this
[__] cop we got to do something
we got to take this [__] down
and i'm listening to all this whole
thing and i'm going oh my god
because it was a one cuban they they
called them this is way
this guy cuban's called the [__] boyle
that's one name they call it papaya
that's the main name that's the
that's the flower of the state papaya
pinga is dick but the other slang is
boyo
you know so uh
i don't even know why i'm telling you
this [__] one of the borrowing his name
was boyotrite that means sad [__]
because he was always he was always sad
you know so
they would call him boyotrite right
there was boyotrite
they all owned these bars
they all on these bars so all these guys
are in this [__] thing these owners
talking about this [__] guy and i
remember boy ota with this depressed eye
going you know let's kill this
[__] and i'm like oh these
[__] gonna kill a [__] cop
so about a week later my mom comes to
the bar i'm getting ready to leave and
she goes listen stay tonight
because my friend eva is having a
santeria thing uh
when a spirit comes down and she talks
to you
now i had been to eva's house before
eva's kids played basketball with me
and i had seen her in action one night
this chick was a mother like a hockey
mom
but once a month she would [__] get
hammered and a spirit would come into
and she'd tell your future
listen guys i seen this [__] open up
because i'm a bar
guy so i watch everything i would see
her open up a bottle of uh what's that
no [__] sir rock
it's 160 [__] proof it's ass water
whatever what's the
what's the grain alcohol whatever that
[__] is right
[__] moonshine wearing jersey
[__]
mmm sean
you see that i got to deal with so
so it's that [__] thing with a
gorilla on it like three x's on it you
know what i'm saying
and they show the gorilla getting shot
in the heart or something
but you're too late right whatever so uh
she [__] drinks this [__] she starts
telling futures and [__] and one night i
watched her drink the whole [__]
thing to the bottom
the next day i went there earlier to see
if this [__] was hungover right cause
you know me dawg i'm a [__] i can't
sleep i had to [__] get to the bottom
of this i didn't believe
i didn't believe in spirits and all that
cuban [__] at that age i was like [__]
this [__]
oh the spirit's gonna get you [__] that
punk ain't gonna [__] get me
so i go over there and uh the one time
and i seen her drank the bottle and the
next morning i went to call for her kids
and she was up making breakfast guys
so i'm like i gotta watch this bitch's
bottles maybe she's filling them up with
water so again i'm like tell me when
your mom
is doing that [__] and i went there that
afternoon that bottle had the [__]
seal on it that [__] was drinking the
grain alcohol right
so there's one night my mom goes let's
go over there eva's going to be there
and she's going to read a couple of us
come with me you know
and i was scared of all that [__] i'm
like i don't want to be in that voodoo
[__]
and i get there this lady comes down
she's sweating she's drinking she's
giving people their futures
and she sees my mother on the corner of
her eye and she walks over to my mother
i never forget this i was eight
and she goes hey there's somebody
bothering you
my mother goes nah she goes yeah yeah
and she takes a white dish
and she gets a candle and she takes the
white dish and palms it
and gets the candle like this she puts
the candle down she flips the dish over
it's like a [__] tortilla
there was like a face on there like i
really [__] up with a beer and she
goes this the guy that's bothering that
undercover cop had a beard
and she took the dish and she smashed on
the floor and she goes give this [__]
seven days
gone i'm sitting there giggling under my
breath
what the [__] right i don't know a
couple days go by i'm in north bergen my
mother was in unison i'm in this town
next to it
i go to school and all the teachers are
talking around the hallway
and i knew something was wasn't right
and they teach and at three o'clock i
get on the
go home i get my bike and i shoot up to
union city and when i walk into the bar
all those guys are there [__]
drinking
[__] drinking up a storm [__] that
[__]
i'm like what's going on there like that
cop died last night
and i'm like holly dynago go to rapido
taxi this is night listen
you see that show on what's the show on
show time with it
with the drug dealer the woman who
killed people the cocaine cowboys
wipe that story on your [__] it's
[__] fake all right
it's fake okay it's 1975. these [__]
crazy cubans had a
taxi cab company called rappy though
taxi they never had a client they were
just delivering blow
you would call and say i want a kilo and
they drive it to your [__] house they
never had a customer
it was called floppy little taxi dig
that [__] again
sesame street people that means fast
rapping though means quicker than a
[__] right
so they said to me i go what happened
who shot him and they're like we don't
know he got shot at rapido taxi so i got
my bicycle one i [__] went up to
rapido taxi
and still they had the light up this is
way before csi there was no csi
they come and look at a bullet he got
shot let's go the [__]
oh no he got shot from that range three
foot who gives a [__] he's dead
i'm gonna sit here and work overtime
he's dead what the [__] who gives a [__]
where the arrow came from he's dead
pack it up and we went in the afternoon
and they had the police tape up rapido
was closed
but in the war on the brick wall we were
taking the [__]
we could take the bullets out of there i
mean it was [__] crazy there was
still bullets on the floor
it was crazy this was [__] crazy i
went back i go mom what happened she
goes i don't know
he went to do a collection and [__]
somebody was waiting for him they
blasted that [__]
i'm like what the [__] that's when the
next day i went to see eva
i'm sorry dog i believe i got a bunch of
enemies you got to take care of you know
what i'm saying
i couldn't [__] believe i don't know
if this was a coincidence i didn't care
after that i believed i'm like there's
something higher out there
this [__] put the voodoo and eve
is still alive today i went when i went
home
last year i stopped by a house to see if
papa was there that's a puerto rican
son's name
and they're still alive and ticking she
still does a little ceremonies once a
[__] month i don't want to be there
right
and like i said this is a bonus story
but let me tell you what happened i mean
that really scared the [__] out of my
father my stepfather said that's it
you guys are killing cops and killing
chickens and drinking bottles
i can't be involved in this [__] i'm
never going to that bar again he stuck
to her he told my mother i'll never go
down there again i just can't deal with
all that [__]
to take away from that story in 1987 i
got locked up in prison
i got out in 1989 and i was in the
halfway house and i had to go for a job
i was in boulder colorado
and i had to go for a school job like i
had to have a job to be in the halfway
last night i want to apply for a job
selling cars i was no problem fill out
this paperwork i fell off the paper he
goes listen you got to meet with three
managers and they'll decide but your
experience will give you the job
so i met with two guys and they said you
got the job
but you got to wait for one more manager
he's coming later on i go really
and they go yeah wait like a half hour
and the guy shows and i shake the guy's
hand i forget what his name was george
something was a spanish name like you
spanish in boulder because there's no
spanish people
and he goes i'm cuban and i go no [__]
were you born in miami
he goes no i go did you grow up in union
city and he goes no
i was born in union city but my father
got shot
and i had to move to virginia
this is that happened in 75 and this
[__] went down in 90. this is how it was
like a call back like i was like holy
[__]
and then we got and then i have another
friend in vegas that whenever i go to
vegas to do the ufc i always have
breakfast with him
and he still knows the cop that was in
the car with him because his father was
the mechanic for all the police cars
and i asked mario mary what did the cops
say he goes when he was getting shot
that day because they shot this cop with
a thousand bullets
they [__] got him they like eight
[__] got him they just kept
shooting on him
the cop that was in the car he said the
door was stuck he couldn't get out
he goes till this day the door got stuck
i could not get the [__] out of the car
so that goes to that story
anybody here will watch prince of the
city or
what's the movie that steve martin's in
where they go down to san diego he's
in the mafia my blue heaven
all you [__] seen hangover too
but i guarantee you don't see a real
[__] movie
like you find oh hang over to oh my god
but a real [__] academy award winner
you guys don't [__] see
what movie was asking my blue heaven is
a great [__] movie did you see it a
couple of times
remember when they're in the restaurant
and that big [__] comes in
his name was ron carobots he was a union
city cop
and after that scandal he had to quit
and one day i seen him in an audition
here like 10 years ago and i go you ron
from print he's also in prince of the
city with tree williams he did some
badass movies
that guy was a [__] union city cop
the reason why he quit was because of
that cop getting murdered
they were all going to go [__] under
once that guy got caught so he all quit
and he became a movie starting to prince
of the city with tree williams and
the rest his history is this doesn't
have something to what i'm talking about
but it does
because after that my stepdad stopped
coming to the [__] bar he was like
i'll never go down there again
and then to make it worse at this time
him and my wife even my wife him and my
mom weren't really tight
and one night my mom came home drunk and
was talking to him
and said do you have a cigarette and he
took the cigarette and instead of giving
it to her he
threw it like this he didn't throw it he
went like this
and she missed it and she looked at him
she goes thank you
so my dad was a scary guy juan was a
scary guy
but my mother was a little scarier okay
my mom was five foot two what do you
want to do type [__]
she had a [__] alias okay the [__]
stabbed somebody in cuba that's why she
had an alias i didn't know until after
she died
so oh yeah my mom didn't [__] around
this shit's in my
blood the valdez side there's a scary
[__] side right
so my stepdad goes to sleep
my mother takes a saint because they're
very religious these [__] she
takes a saint
like a statue and busts it over his head
while he was sleeping
that's how school she came from she's
like [__] i'll kill you in your
sleep [__]
she busted that thing over his head he
got up like [__] discombobulated
bleeding and [__] didn't know what's
going on so she's running out of the
room he takes a bottle with
charlemagne shalom gerlain and throws it
at her and it hits the thing
and it hits her in the [__] head
right so
i'm not even there i'm at a buddy's
house
and my buddy's mother wakes me up and
she goes coco i think you better go home
your mother just called this cause
something's going on i go i can't get
over there
i go can your son give me a ride your
older son she goes yeah
as me and him we're making the turn onto
giving that terrorist my block
my mother was outside in the winter with
a house dress on
it was like 10 below steam is coming out
of her body from the blood
and she's out there smoking a cigarette
with a knife in her hand waiting for
this [__] outside right
so as i walk up and go what happened she
goes [__] one that [__] will
never hit me again and meanwhile
juan comes tearing out with [__] half
his head hanging
he's like you crazy [__] and she's like
i [__] cut you out of here right now
[__]
he's like [__] it i'm leaving right so
me and my friend take my mother to a
diner and we take it to thee first then
we take it to the hospital get stitched
up
and i remember after my mom got set up
she got in the car
and she looked at me oh my are you all
right you know and i was like a young
man by that time oh my you're right and
she goes listen
i hope you learned a valuable lesson
tonight don't ever let nobody
ever [__] with you she goes that
[__] will never [__] with me
again
and she pulled over and she called the
house and he hands and she goes listen
i'm gonna sleep in my friend's house
tonight i'll be home in the morning when
i get home have all your [__] the [__]
out of there
you know guys leave like something
guys always leave something to come back
that [__]
took everything the first shot he fit
everything in his [__] car
he never came back he called me like
three days later you know i love you dog
but i can't be in the house with that
[__] she broke my [__] head i got
like 30 stitches he had like 30 stitches
this way she [__] smashed them guys
because of the [__] missed cigarette
and that was the end of their
relationship
and i loved them you know i loved them
even though by this time it was like
guys you know by the time you're 13 it's
even worse
because now they're like you can't do
this you can't do that [__] you're not
my father
so it was like i heard him you know he
taught me his playbook
he gave me his [__] life playbook all
the things i lived by today is the
things i emulated from him
you know when i [__] had to get down
i had to get down i had to think like
him
because when he got down he got down you
know if you didn't go to school
you can go out and play with him like it
was like i'm going out to play no you
didn't go to school
if i didn't go to work with him like one
day and i go ahead and eat ten dollars
mama tala pinga
[__] you suck your own dick now you got
nothing you didn't go to work
and it's true his mentality was true go
[__] yourself you wanted to play
you know he'd say let's go work i could
make 200 hours and i want to go play
basketball basketball
are you [__] kidding me to pay you
200 [__] dollars so he was like [__]
i can't get to this kid no more i had
lost him and it was a shame because i
really loved him